طب يوسف كانه الامر اصبح هكذا حلم والحلم
اصبح ايضا حتى بسيط في مفرداته يعني كلمه
السر سير سير بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي مع
وليد الرجرك
نتمنى ان شاء الله مقابل الحلم
هذا كان شعر بطوله
على ما حققه المغرب اظن شيء تاريخي سيبقى
في التاريخ الوصول الى المربع الذهبي لكن
انا عندما تقترب على خطوه واحده فانك
الان ضغوطات كلها على المنتخب الفرنسي في
الاعتقادي المنتخب الظاهر عنده فرصه كبيره
اول شيء لانه في بلد عربي ما هذا الجمهور
فرصه لن تتعوض مره اخرى
مع الدعم الجماهيري هنا
للانصار منتخب المغربي والدعم العربي
همم
انهم يلعبون بدون اي تخوف بدون اي ضغوطات
يعرفونها مباراه مهمه شعب كله وراء
المنتخب يساند المنتخب وصلوا الى ابعد
نقطه ولا واحد كان يتمنى او يعتقد انه يصل
اليها وبالتالي الان علينا بالاستمتاع
اكثر مع كذلك الرغبه في الفوز وتحقيق
الفوز وتحقيق الاهم والوصول الى النهائي
هدف اعتقاد سيكون اكبر انجاز لو تحقق
واكبر هديه لهذه الدوله قطر وللمسؤوليه
قطر على هذا التنظيم الجيد
وكذلك وصول المنتخب
الاخضر
في عيدها الوطني يوم 18
ان شاء الله